So, tell me
what's on your mind.
Well, it just hurts.
You know?
When you're poor,
all you want to be
is not.
Poor in Louisiana
somehow feels extra poor.
There's something about being poor
next to a swamp that makes you go,
“Oh I might not make it
out of this s***, okay.”
There's no polite way to say so.
Across from me on the sidewalk
there was a crackhead that was dancing, right?
But he wasn't dancing to any music,
just to the
rhythm of the crack.
I got just famous
enough that it's like
I have big t****** or something.
Like, I got to be very careful
when I move
through these streets.
COVID killed millions of people,
but somehow everyone
that I owe money lived.
Laughter is a means to process.
It's a way to exhale hurt.
Some people cry.
Some people scream.
And I...
laugh.
Josh Johnson!